le campus de l'institut supérieur de
l'environnement été officiellement
inauguré ce mardi 11 décembre
cette école privée accueille chaque
semaine plus de 200 étudiants venus de
toute la france
la structure propose après le
baccalauréat des cursus en deux trois ou
cinq ans objectif préparer les étudiants
sur ce secteur porteur donc les
étudiants venant d'un point de vue
ingénierie étudié par exemple de
matières comme la biologie chimie la
physique les mathématiques
l'environnement l'écologie ou le droit
de la nature le droit de l'environnement
et d'autres matière de management
retrouve du développement durable et la
rse tout ça pour des débouchés pour
s'occuper au sein des entreprises des
enjeux environnementaux et de
développement durable après être resté
pendant 25 ans à saint quentin en
yvelines l'école s'est installé près de
la gare versailles chantiers pour
continuer son expansion
je pense que l'institution à
l'environnement ça se marie parfaitement
avec versailles et tout ce qu'on essaie
aujourd'hui de faire autour de cette
thématique qui est l'environnement et
plus largement ce qu'on appelle la ville
nature versailles c'est unique est connu
c'est une ville dont le nom résonne dans
le monde entier et je pense que c'est un
atout pour cet institut qui a maintenant
plusieurs années d'existence de s'être
installé ici l'année dernière près de
deux tiers des étudiants réussi à
trouver un travail avant la fin de leur
cursus dans l'école l'établissement
espère réaliser des chiffres similaires
pour cette première année à versailles
[Applaudissements]